are you
uh afraid of death
i mean it's easy for me to say no as i
sit here probably not about to die but
is this the ufc question can you defeat
any opponent is that the answer yes the
answer is of course
yes and uh i don't have they're not
around they're not here are they yeah
exactly
but i mean you uh do you ponder your own
mortality
maybe another context to that is you
mentioned two deaths
for martial artists i think that's
actually why honestly even though
at a relatively young age i think
mortality is something that i'm aware of
more maybe more than the average person
i think probably most athletes can speak
to this and
anyone that's had so i've managed to to
slide out of a couple near-death
experiences personally you know mostly
river related um because i'm an idiot
but um
i regret nothing but uh yeah yeah but uh
thank god we're here
but um yeah it it is seeing seeing the
end
and seeing going well
what's going to happen i guess i think
it comes back to kind of what we're
discussing about belief structure and
belief system
i think a lot of times if i recognize
that no matter what i do
it's all going to end one day and then
you go well why were we here what would
i do
am i going to make it to 40. i have no
idea i'd like to hope so
that i had no idea that i was going to
make it to to the age that i am now
am i going to make it to 80. how much of
that is in my control
much of it is not i mean it's so funny
it's an interesting like back to the
belief structure again like locus of
internal and external locus of control
you know what's facilitative versus
what's true
and you know i think accepting personal
responsibility for more than is on my
control is is probably a positive
but at the same time recognizing that
much of much is not in my control i was
fortunate enough to be
born in the united states fortunate
enough to you know to not
knock on wood have a serious disease
that i'm not aware of right now
um i didn't do any of that i just showed
up
that was really fortunate and i i guess
that doesn't diminish the fact that i
try to make decent choices but it works
in concert with it and i
i guess um when i when you go
is death what i want right now no
no i should think not and again it's
easy for me to be relatively calm about
as i'm not staring it in the face
but what i would care a lot more about
is is
how you live that's what's in my control
and i can't control if as i walk out of
this building a helicopter falls on me
worrying about that i can't control
maybe i maybe i have cancer now and i
don't know it
i really hope not but um there's
something about meditating on the fact
that
it could end today outside your control
that can uh clarify your thinking about
yeah the the fact that life is amazing
like just kind of
yeah helping you enjoy this moment even
if life was horrible
let's say for instance it was it was you
live at one of those times or places and
this place
still exists in this world today that
life is brutal
and metal and whatever all and short and
painful
would you still want it and again as i'm
sitting here not
not on fire physically it's easy to say
yes but i would i'm confident i still
i'll plant my feet and say yes any of
life any life is amazing and beautiful
and
a gift an unbelievable gift that none of
us have earned
for the record i hate the word earned a
lot of times earn yeah you earn but it's
like
there's a lot of a lot of good fortune
in earning and that's back to
do i want justice or do i want grace and
i guess we're all fortunate to be where
we are no matter where we are and
hopefully it should give us
some sense of perspective some sense of
compassion for other people but also
like like you said a sense of peace if
it all ended right now would i
be happy with what a with life to this
point i'm like of course
would you like to live a little longer
yeah i would try to do more
and try to live rightly to the best that
i know how which over time will
hopefully continue to evolve in
a positive direction but if the answer
to that is no
i i guess uh that's that's always
that's a sign that that what i'm doing
is not what i'm meant to be doing and i
mean you're familiar with the tecumseh
before so there's a i've got one
actually if you could give me 10 seconds
i'll read this one out this is
a personal favorite basically and i
think it sums up
i mean again like it's one of those
quotes on the internet like when abraham
lincoln said don't believe everything
you read online
um but uh this is you know i it's
again uh attributed but it's like so
live your life that the fear of death
can never enter your heart
trouble knowing about their religion
respect others in their view and demand
that they respect yours
love your life perfect your life
beautify all things in your life
seek to make your life long and its
purpose in the service of your people
prepare a noble death song for the day
when you go over the great divide
always give a word or sign a salute when
meeting or passing a friend even a
stranger when in a lonely place
show respect to all people and grovel to
none
when you arise in the morning give
thanks for the food and for the joy of
living
if you see no reason for giving thanks
the fault lies only in yourself
abuse no one and no thing for abuse
turns the wise ones to fools and robs
the spirit of its vision
when it comes your time to die be not
like those whose hearts are filled with
the fear of death
so that when their time comes they weep
and pray for a little more time to live
their lives over again in a different
way
sing your death song and die like a hero
going home
you